I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight
's trial balloon that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now just like the Spy balloon itself
America's China apologists were floating
around today I am kind of prepared to
accept the Chinese uh explanation for uh
this balloon I've had some personal
experience with using balloons as a
reconnaissance devices and they're not
very efficient they don't think the
Chinese would expend the political
Capital here Washington lost its
Collective mind yesterday on this the
Chinese do spy on on us I think they're
you know this this goes back to maybe
some kind of old Cold War worry about
you know about something kind of
tangible looking up at us the joke I had
in my household is that you know they
are they kind of getting a preview of
the next season of Yellowstone
Yellowstone
what a riot
send him out on the comedy circuit well
the Chinese are laughing at us that's
for sure the role of the Pentagon under
Biden seems clear
unless we're talking about sending
billions and weapons to Ukraine
well the pentagon's role is pretty much
one of an observer once it's over a body
of water will you shoot it down the
North American Aerospace Defense command
continues to monitor it closely who is
controlling this balloon right now is
the Chinese government controlling the
movement of the balloon or is it just
floating with airstreams right now we're
monitoring the situation closely we will
continue to monitor we'll continue to
review our options and provide
information and updates well since we're
in the observation and monitoring
business NORAD simply tracking the Reds
balloon
it does have experience though in doing
this tracking thing after all the
continental U.S NORAD region also known
as konar
continues our no-fill mission securing
the airspace over the United States
still on December 24th we take on the
extra special mission of tracking Santa
Claus
just like they do with Santa NORAD
should set up a website for all of us to
follow to track this round figure
you've said several times that the US
was reviewing its options
I'd like to some clarity is the option
of shooting down the balloon
particularly as it's going over more
populated areas off the table is that
still amongst the options that the US
military is considering we're just not
going to get into an hour by hour where
the balloon is so we will do our best to
keep you and the public informed
General did give us a little
play-by-play
it currently is traversing the
continental United States right now we
assess that it'll probably be over the
United States for a few few days but
we'll continue to monitor review our
options and keep you updated as as we
can
he's like Al Roker and the Doppler radar
I think this is humiliating with the
United States that even just General
Wesley Clark and former Obama sect deaf
Leon Panetta they felt the need to chime
in it is our airspace that we have to
protect uh so I I suspect that there are
ways to be able to go after this balloon
uh whether whether to shoot it down or
whether to intercept it uh in some way
or whether to interfere with what the
maneuverability of the balloon which uh
obviously is of concern and former CIA
officer Bob bear was even more blunt
echoing what the angle just warned about
last night
this entire exercise was a trial balloon
literally floated by China to see how
long it would take for us to react
forcefully the Spy balloon the Chinese
would take our play they've taken our
planes down that weren't even flying in
their airspace uh they forced them down
we let it go we keep on
um
appeasing the Chinese and they'll keep
pushing and for all those Pentagon
groupies who were buying the line that
the generals are worried about
collateral damage on the ground if they
shot it down okay get your head screwed
on straight
if we can hit home plate and Yankee
Stadium with the cruise missile launched
thousands of miles away I think we could
pop a balloon without endangering human
life
and if not maybe we should reconsider
what we're getting for that 850 billion
dollar a year we spend on defense at
this point
and our secretary of state should have
immediately canceled not postponed his
trip to Beijing over this Chinese
provocation this trip that was planned
by the Secretary of State we hope that
ultimately things will settle down and
they'll be able to get back to
negotiating table no now that's stupid
the U.S statement on this should have
been short and to the point
something like we consider this move to
be a deliberate provocation and a
blatant violation of our airspace and
our sovereignty we have taken Swift
action to eliminate the potential
intelligence threat to the CCP action
posed to our nation and Any Nation
organization that attempts anything
similar will find the same result all
future high-level discussions with China
are hereby postponed indefinitely
that's what we should have said
now this balloon may or may not be
really good at collecting sensitive
information we have no idea
but that's frankly irrelevant
by launching it
watching it and then watching the US's
slow response
XI is learning a lot about us the great
United States
we appear to be more worried about
offending the Chinese more afraid of
protesters storming our capital
then protecting our own Homeland against
a communist aggressor
the sad fact that as long as Biden is
president
China does have all the leverage our
military is hyper focused on Europe our
supply chains are still in China we've
depleted our Munitions by sending so
much to Ukraine and our military is
mired in woke nonsense
the fact that she lied about covid took
Hong Kong Enslaved the uyghurs and
instead of moving to decouple from the
evil regime been on world domination we
just keep going back for more
for better relations Wall Street wants
more business engagement universities
want more Chinese students
it's frankly all of it disgusting and
it's un-American and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else